voilà on respire bien
une grande inspiration
et on expire à première vue il pourrait
s'agir d'une simple séance de relaxation
mais les soins prodigués aujourd'hui par
Valérie maillot socio-esthéticienne sont
à destination des personnes atteintes du
cancer ou en rémission afin de les
accompagner au mieux l'associo
esthétique c'est prodiguer des soins de
bien-être de confort à toute personne en
fait fragilisée par la maladie notamment
ici le cancer mais aussi par la
vieillesse
le handicap encore peu connu la pratique
existe pourtant depuis
1970 alliant écoute et soins chaque
séance s'adapte aux besoins des patients
et aux spécificités des pathologies ça
m'a apporté beaucoup parce que j'ai pu
d'abord ça m'a rassurer un peu et j'ai
vu énormément de gens j'ai des
énormément de gens à Poissy parce que
c'est malheureusement c'est très mal
il y a beaucoup de formulaires il y a
beaucoup de d'associations mais c'est
très mal connu par les patients
eux-mêmes à l'hôpital
aujourd'hui cette pratique se
démocratise notamment grâce à sa prise
en charge par différents acteurs parmi
eux les dispositifs d'aide à la
coordination du ministère de la Santé
cette prise en charge est un point en
moins pour les malades après tout le
parcours de soins que j'avais un petit
peu commencé les opérations la chimio
etc j'ai découvert que en fait on avait
le droit à cinq séances de
socio-esthétiques par an pris en charge
et donc via DAC Nord
j'ai rencontré Valérie la société
esthéticienne qui chaque rendez-vous m'a
apporté une petite bulle de bonheur de
confort de de bien-être dans tous ces
traitements douloureux la
socio-esthétique est aujourd'hui
reconnue comme un soin à part entière
apportant réconfort et confiance en soi
des points clés pour accompagner les
malades sur le chemin de la guérison